turning to Washington now where former
president Trump wants the Supreme Court
to weigh in on the investigation into
classified documents seized by the FBI
at Mar-A-Lago Scott McFarland is outside
the high court to explain what exactly
Trump hopes to achieve with this Scott
good morning to you that's always a
question what's Mr Trump's in-game hey
Gail good morning this is a limited
legal challenge but it appears to be a
play by the Trump team to give more
access to more of those documents
they're asking the Supreme Court to
allow that outside legal expert that
special Master to review documents Mark
classified could also allow Trump's
lawyers though to review those documents
as It prepares to mount a defense the
bottom line this request prolongs the
legal battle however Trump's request
would have no impact on the Department
of Justice investigation because it
doesn't seek to block federal agents
from examining those records the Trump
team is hoping the conservative leaning
Court to which the former president
nominated three of the justices will
take up this case and it's initially
assigned to Clarence Thomas who oversees
emergency requests from the federal
courts in Florida justice justice Thomas
has ordered the Department of Justice to
respond to this motion by Tuesday and
history is not on the Trump team's side
last year the high court blocked a
request from the Trump legal team to
block the Handover of Records to the
January 6th select commit Nate
Scott thank you